the same company this is funny the same
company that did the strippers and
escorts
by day same phone number
same everything because it was called
like something's entertainment whatever
his name was right like Gary's energy
his name it was like Gary's
entertainment Gary's entertainment yeah
they would send me out they go hey would
you also want to make more money
by going to kids birthdays parties kids
birthdays as
uh you know dressed as Winnie the Pooh
or Kids characters
[Music]
and so I said yes
wait this is the same same company so
you could either have Winnie the Pooh
yeah same phone number or crackhead
Candice yes depending on the party
chunky Candace or Winnie the Pooh but
were you winning well the Winnie the
Pooh is about awkward stories though
they
the guy let's say was like uh low
business morals the guy who owned this
company he did not really give a [__]
about anything and he
would send me out again I was kind of
last option
the people he had that didn't want to do
it I'd get those gigs so they would send
me into North Philadelphia which is
pretty bad area rough area
to do some uh I remember being Elmo one
time and then also the costumes were not
uh
film quality let's say they were like
like
um Times Square
yes very much like like shitty carrying
it in a trash bag like burlap costumes
yeah Elmo so you're Elmo Tickle Me Elmo
um but the the most awkward one was I
went to uh
a party it was at nine o'clock at night
they wanted me to be there I got there I
find out when I walk in wait 9 p.m
dressed as Elmo it was Winnie the Pooh
Winnie the Pooh but I just have Winnie
the Pooh in my I understand but if
you're dressed at Winnie the Pooh if
anybody has designed wanted Winnie the
Pooh at a party yeah 9 00 p.m I'm a
parent you are too you have to yeah kid
um what party have you ever thrown where
the kid would be entertained by Winnie
the Pooh or Elmo that would happen like
after 6 p.m correct the kind of party
that that would happen at is
a uh black thuggy house party where
there was just two babies in high chairs
um and I walked in it was I mean people
playing dice
the 40s the everyone's smoking weed and
there's two babies in high chairs with
Cheerios in front of them and I come in
and I'm very nervous I find out through
the guy who
you know and they walk on he's like he's
like What's Up [__] you're like
Yeah I'm
I'm here for to be the Winnie the Pooh
and he's like oh yeah he goes where's
the balloons and presents
and I was like excuse me he goes the
balloon's in prison and with this guy
the owner of the company will do is
he'll throw and he'll say a bunch of
[__] he just wants to sell the gig
and figure out he'll deal with it when
you get there right balloons is I've
never heard of that bringing balloons
and presents for a kid I don't know is
odd you're Winnie the Pooh yeah it's
also odd that you walked in without the
costume just the costume in the bag like
I I've thrown parties for my kids the
the person I don't see the person out of
costume really they walk to the door
like that really don't they usually get
dressed in the car has anybody
else in in here throwing a party for a
kid do you ever see I got my daughter
adore the Explorer and you and Dora came
in without being an Explorer I think she
may have come in the princess costume
actually yeah they always come into the
costumes on you it's like walking around
Disneyland and going I want to see
Mickey hey let me just put this head on
yeah he's got the head off yeah
so okay but the funny that you got
Winnie in a sack so I think guys it's
balloons and presents I go I was not
aware of anything balloons and he's
pissed he calls the guy I guess the guy
gives him some sort of price break
enough
to say like all right fine go upstairs
and change
so I go upstairs
and um I go in the room I'm putting on
this Winnie the Pooh costume
and uh when I close the door
so at one point the guy yo I closed the
bedroom door and the guy yelled up at
one point he's like hey don't close that
bedroom door
and I was like you know already did
and he uh he starts cursing because
something's wrong broken with the door
they can't get it open
so 30 minutes and I'm not exaggerating
taking their final solution is we gotta
knock the hinges off wait you're
standing in a strange person are you
wearing a Winnie a poo I'm holding the
head oh I said the the door it literally
Falls like an old Philadelphia house the
door falls with smoke and I'm let's
remember the movie The Right Stuff I'm
just like holding the Winnie the Pooh
costume like I said like uh yeah the
right stuff is
they're holding their helmets and
walking in slow motion you're in a in a
in a crack house room in a furry costume
holding a bear head yeah it's not like
the right stuff that's the wrong stuff
it's the wrong stuff for sure but it
looks so Regal waiting there and legal
they were yeah I was very very important
with my costume on
and I went downstairs
and uh you know I had like they gave me
a CD of like you know kids songs to play
and I was like all right they're all
they're so frustrated with me
who gave you the CD the people there
yeah well I bring it they always had me
bring a CD so I go hey can we put this
I'm just a kid's music to dance to and
you know do the hokey pokey well
I was yes I did but I was like uh hey
can you guys put the CD in for the music
and he goes just dance to what's on
[__] so I danced for two kids in
uh in height chairs eating Cheerios to
Dr Dre's uh Chronic 2001 album
awkwardly and then when it was over
I go to the guy I was like oh and I'm
trying like did you turn around I
thought I was going to have that I
thought we were having that moment and I
was like hey man I was like the kids are
adorable it was a pleasure thank you
sorry for the confusion when I gotta go
I'm gonna go upstairs and change and get
out of here and he goes nah you ain't
going back upstairs get out of here now
and I I knew he was serious but I just
treated it like he was kidding I was
like ha crazy right if I just left like
this I was like but I'm just gonna head
upstairs and take care of this and he
was like no honey shove me out the door
like hard and then uh told two guys on
the stoop to like make sure I get to my
car but like aggressive and then I just
ran to my mom's Chevette stick shift
Chevette and drove it home in a Winnie
the Pooh costume with the head off
[Music]